former Egyptian President Hosni Mubarak
has died at the age of 91 Mubarak came
to power in the early 1980s and ruled
Egypt for three decades during that time
he forged stronger ties with the United
States and Israel while crushing
opposition at home that was until 2011
when he was ousted from power during the
Arab Spring
after more than 1 million Egyptians
angry about poverty and repression
called for him to go he ceded control to
the military he served time in prison
but his conviction was later overturned
I say yet Baba it was one last triumph
for Hosni Mubarak Egypt's former
president was acquitted after a trial
that lasted years the judges found him
innocent of involvement in the killing
of protesters during the 2011 Arab
Spring uprising that ended his 30-year
rule his career ended with a revolution
it began with an assassination in
October 1981 at a military parade
Islamist militants shot and killed then
President Anwar Sadat Mubarak the Vice
President escaped with minor injuries
and took over the presidency in the same
year he implemented emergency laws as
part of his battle against militants he
also expanded police powers in another
of his first moves he told the u.s. he
would stick by his country's 1979 peace
agreement with Israel the first by any
Arab nation Mubarak became an important
mediator between Israel and the
Palestinians for three decades he was
seen as a guarantor of stability in the
Middle East in return his country was
given billions of dollars in aid from
the US he was courted in Europe and
respected by his Raley's and Arabs alike
but at home Mubarak showed a different
face he cracked down on Islamists after
they orchestrated attacks and threatened
his rule Egypt's democracy was little
more than a facade all elections were
rigged
Mubarak did little to address the
poverty afflicting millions of Egyptians
as his inner circle and his own family
became wealthy as Egyptians resentment
grew and mass demonstrations broke out
Mubarak reacted with force when that
failed to curb the protests he attempted
to make concessions but in the end the
might of the Arab masses forced him to
step down Mubarak was put on trial in
jailed for six years mostly spent in a
military prison having served his
sentence for corruption the former
president was released and returned home
to his villa one of many properties
owned by his family his wife and sons
administered the assets accumulated
during his time in office
Mubarak ruled Egypt for 30 years honored
and feared in equal measure